Bon bah c'est bien.
Hein ?
Encore une bonne réunion qui se termine.
On peut y aller.
Bonne soirée.
Les mystères sont de mise !
Aaaaaah !
Mais arrête avec cette devise toutes les deux minutes !
Et puis tu la cries maintenant en plus.
C'est vrai ! Vous en pensez quoi vous ?
Soyez pas choqués comme ça.
Je me suis emporté.
Mais est-ce que, les mystères sont de mise...
Ça veut vraiment dire quelque chose ?
Il est comme ça lui.
Ah... ok.
Bien.
Apparement...
Quelqu'un a essayé de planter ce couteau dans mon dos.
Sans cette armure de dragon...
J'étais plus là.
C'est officiellement une tentative de meurtre.
Je pense que, malheureusement, l'assassin est parmi vous.
C'est ridicule, hein.
Bah oui, c'est ridicule.
C'est pas moi, hein.
Suceur.
Y a un moyen très simple de déterminer à qui appartient cette arme.
Que chacun sorte son couteau !
On est tous censé avoir un couteau.
C'est la tradition mais...
Ça sert essentiellement pour la bouffe.
Clarisse ?
Bah moi j'ai pas de couteau, je suis pas une sauvage...
Belyr ?
Très bien.
A présent...
Que chacun sorte son deuxième couteau !
Quoi ?
J'ai pas de deuxième couteau, bon j'ai un deuxième couteau...
Mais c'est parce que le château est hyper dangereux aussi.
Et merde...
C'était Belyr.
Les autres avaient pas de mobile.
Il avait pas son deuxième couteau traditionnel.
Et aussi, y avait son nom sur la lame.
Je le savais depuis le début.
Mais enfin !
Mais je vous dis que c'est pas possible !
Je suis Daniel De Belyr, c'est moi le seigneur de ce château !
Le cachot, je l'ai fait construire !
Avant on stockait du vin et des enclumes ici.
C'est moi qui est fait tout changer !
Bonjour prisonniers. Alors moi, je préfère vous le dire tout de suite...
Vous avez pas intérêt à faire de conneries.
Parce que si vous faites un truc contre moi, ça se retournera contre vous.
Parce que moi je suis le seigneur de ce château.
Donc quand je sortirai d'ici, j'oublierai pas !
Bah oui, je parle vite mais j'ai pas peur !
Ah non, j'ai pas peur, c'est mon débit naturel.
C'est à vous de vous adapter, moi je m'en fous !
De tout façon, moi je vais pas rester ici très très longtemps.
Parce que moi, à l'heure qu'il est, mes amis, y sont déjà en train de plaider pour ma défense.
C'est un connard !
C'est vrai non ?
Oui mais, en même temps, quel serait le meilleur châtiment pour la connarité ?
On veut pas qu'il souffre.
Mais un peu de changement, ça ferait du bien quand même.
Oui.
Non, mais je crois qu'on se comprend tout à fait.
Vous voulez du changement.
Mais vous voulez pas qu'il souffre.
C'est ça.
Parfait.
Bon.
Bah vous inquiétez pas.
Je serai clément avec Belyr.
Hommes de cachot !
Je sais que votre monde est plein de violence et de cruauté.
Un univers pleins de peur...
Et de ténèbres.
Oh les préjugés, quoi.
Genre on est des sauvages...
C'est ça...
Bah c'est le cachot, les gars.
Oui non mais ça va, on est civilisé.
On est pas des bêtes non plus.
Y a pas de...
Oh non !
Ou de...
Oh mais non !
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça là ?
C'est incroyable ça.
Alors oui, peut-être, parfois ça arrive.
Si y a un feeling à la cool entre nous...
Bon on est en galère, on se rend des petits services.
Voilà, mais ça reste exceptionnel.
Et...
Fais attention parce que, je suis désolé, mais toi, avec tes clichés...
Et bah ça donne pas envie.
Ouais, demande rien, il se passera quedal.
Je suis désolé.
Parce que je pensais que les conditions étaient hyper difficiles.
Ah ouais, non par contre, ça c'est vrai que c'est horrible.
Il fait froid, c'est humide, y a rien à bouffer.
On se fait tabasser tous les jours, on boit de la pisse...
Mais c'est pour ça, faut être dans l'entraide, faut être copains quoi.
Waow.
Ces forçats me donnent une leçon de vie.
Voir des illettrés réagir avec tant de noblesse...
Bah moi, ça me... ça me bouleverse, voilà.
Le mec...
Il a des pieds, mais tout propres !
Mais genre, propres, ils sont blancs !
Des pieds blancs !
Ouais et genre il a pas d'odeur quoi.
Genre il sent rien.
Je sais même pas où il est, des fois, dans la pièce.
Il est là ?
Non.
Je crois qu'ils m'aiment bien.
C'est la première fois que je me fait des potes aussi vite.
Puis j'apprends pleins de trucs.
Tiens, par exemple, quand tu mets ta main devant la bouche là, comme ça.
Et bah ça veut dire que c'est gênant ce que tu dis.
Paraît que le nouveau seigneur...
Ça se passe pas super bien, hein.
Je pense que cette aventure va faire de moi un meilleur seigneur.
Dès que je sortirai d'ici...
Je m'arrangerai pour leur offrir une couverture en plus.
Et des chaussettes.
Parce que ça pue.
Belyr ?
Regardez qui voilà.
Aelys.
Bonjour.
Alors...
Comment ça se passe ici ?
Ça se passe hyper bien, figure toi.
Je me suis fait plein de nouveaux copains.
Et on s'éclate comme des petits foufous.
Ça sonnait sexuel ?
Ah non, non, mais...
Parce que c'est pas sexuel, hein.
Oui mais je juge pas.
Non mais ça aurait pu hein, mais...
Je vais pas rester longtemps par contre.
Ah ouais, pourquoi ?
T'as d'autres potes à trahir ?
Non, parce que ça sent mauvais.
Du coup, ça te dérange pas, on finit la conversation dehors ?
C'est plus sympa.
Oh bah non ! Tu peux pas sortir !
Oh bah oui, parce que t'es au cachot.
T'es tellement au cachot.
C'est puérile ça.
Non !
Ça c'est puérile.
Ah oui.
Bien, après avoir beaucoup réfléchi.
Et discuté avec les autres.
Voilà ta sentence.
Tu sortiras mardi.
Ouais.
Parce que dans deux jours, il fera beau.
Et je veux qu'il y ait une belle lumière au moment ou le peuple assistera à ton exécution.